we're seeing knocked up the movie  knocked up with seth rogen remember when  craig robinson is the bouncer at the  nightclub  and when she's pregnant and she brings  her sister and the sister's older she's  like dang in this nightclub i feel kind  of old and the other girl's pregnant and  he walks up and goes and craig robin's  like i can't be having old ladies and  pregnant [ __ ] up in here what the  [ __ ] man  that's funny that line of that movie was  [ __ ] up but he said but i would i  would [ __ ] you up was that seth rogen  stop that  don't do that to me  bro what are you doing  why did you add that that was so creepy  but perfect  imagine your first time on acid okay let  me just get this going  [Laughter]  oh this horrible camera gets closer to  your eye  very [ __ ]  clockwork exactly  [Music]